did you see the fight
i didn't see i didn't see it even i
didn't even see a frame of it bro
people really loved it even knowing the
ending i was like this is [ __ ] is it
just like they were just throwing
haymakers and not following you don't
see heavyweights do this yeah you don't
see heavyweights do this because usually
especially with heavyweight boxers
usually they never start young i mean
even deante wilder right i think he was
playing football maybe or something like
that and then he started boxing
yeah so i mean if you're big and you
live in america yeah like you're not
choosing boxing no there are other
sports who will make way more money have
a much easier life yes right so tyson
fury comes from a legit boxing family
like a dynasty
mike tyson named after mike by his
father i love is that i didn't
you know asap rocky is named after rock
him
no yeah oh this is it okay so you decide
what your kid's gonna be before he's
yeah old enough to decide for himself
well yeah and it works out yeah a lot of
rappers a lot of people were named after
rappers he just happens to be good
enough
so so they go and they fight and um this
is the trilogy fight and everybody for
myself included thought tyson fury was
just going to walk all over him like
just because
trilogy fight the way dave and trans
people as a trilogy
so uh
yeah when the trans person kissed dave
at the weigh-in i knew that was
going to be
[Laughter]
so so they're basically in there and uh
deontay comes a little bit more prepared
for this one and they were [ __ ]
slugging oh we're talking about like 240
i think deontay was 245 and then tyson
was 277. this is a lot of weight this is
heavyweight division one punch you go
down that's it that's why it's
interesting it's like the lighter guys
are fun to watch because they're so
skilled they're running around but at
the end of the day it's like they can
just pound each other's heads it's rare
to get these big knockouts manny
pacquiao was so exciting because here's
this little guy that could actually pack
a punch right like you guys can't
remember last time floyd knocked someone
out
you ever watched do you ever go to a
floyd fight yeah
it was like watching a guy
in
fast forward and the other person's
it was like oh this is just not fair
yeah yeah yeah it was just so great i
saw floyd canelo live it was [ __ ]
unreal but anyway so they start fight
and they're swinging and
uh it looks like tyson is gonna kind of
start bullying wilder
and then wilder catches him with a
really short right hand and drops him
and then drops him again at the end of
the round so all of a sudden you're like
holy [ __ ] right like i don't even know
what's happening what's gonna happen and
then the rest of the fight even though
fury's starting to come on and starting
to outbox and starting to bully him you
know that all it takes is one shot the
guy already went down so for 11 rounds
it's just this scintillating non-stop
action from heavyweights you've never
seen it from heavyweights and
and then fury knocks them out in just
like this amazingly
uh beautiful i think he dips on her hit
something like an overhand right
finishes him they stop the fight deontay
while they show so much [ __ ] heart
like both guys leave the fight
beloved yeah everybody who watched it
was like yo both of y'all if you ever
fight again i will watch you guys fight
again the worst part of the whole fight
is that uh deontay didn't want to shake
his hand afterwards like why
he was just like ego problems yeah so
they had beef after the other fights
like he he accused him of cheating and
like yeah he's been like
he's a soloist that's it he's he's a
he's he never mentions the fact that
you're not in shape he never says
i don't like getting beat up by a guy
who's not a guy who's who works for uh
for ups
we do live in an interesting time though
like uh i was talking to my girl's dad
about this but like we're like tom brady
and
tyson fury yeah like there's not a
single abdominal muscle between the two
of them yeah these are the most dominant
people in their respective sports yeah
and i'm watching this [ __ ] fight and
i get and i asked that probably like
twitter instagram but i'm just like who
was i talking there's a guy in the nba
played for milwaukee
and chicago
jabari parker yeah yeah parker yeah yeah
yeah and he just has
like he's a little puff like doughy but
you know what that is and no no
no no i
i said somebody i know that's why i was
like why is he in bad shape when they go
that guy eats perfectly really and he
can't he just has a soft looking body he
doesn't he's not on the sauce no usually
guys like that yeah of course they're on
the sauce yeah but
interesting yeah some guys just can't
get they're just dope like will ferrell
can run marathons
and he just says doughy and some people
just got bad bodies you're off the bread
you'll be good
you still have carbs you'll be [ __ ]
good all right cool anyway i'm i'm
literally watching this fight and i'm
like
what you stay off carbs you'll be good
jabari parker that's your problem yeah
oh thank you you're listening to my
partner yeah
i bet he is from what i hear he's off
carbs no
no way tom brady's on the carbs tom
brady's on carbs
he's not on car he's [ __ ] like
what are you talking about it's like a
tiny [ __ ] he eats avocados have you
seen him without a shirt ice cream say
what have you seen without a shirt this
is like a guy who's about to fall
like a guy he's like
cops yeah bring the cops in i'll talk to
him
what nah yeah i saw the picture where'd
you say it i don't remember
where uh tom brady i think is like in
for his age is in very good shape for
his aj's in great shape but he's also
the greatest football player in history
and he's never had an amazing physique
right just like tyson right well that's
the thing where i think if you're i
think now
just because it's like you look at like
johnny unitas those guys didn't know
about nutrition yeah and they had day
jobs don't worry don't look at that day
jobs but they these guys can just be
about no black working out
you ever watch uh uh i was just there's
a picture of len dawson
sorry in like halftime with a super bowl
the championship or something smoking
cigarettes smoking a cigarette drinking
a beer at half time
karen used to smoke cigarettes in the
dugout baseball makes sense yeah yeah
they still do tobacco yeah to this day
you could do other things while you play
baseball yeah but football is wild it's
widely yeah
anyway quarterback sauced up
making reads that's gonna be the future
of the combine they're gonna be looking
for fat guys hundred percent yeah we're
gonna see some guy be like yeah too many
abs it's the neck oh well it's some
position
i don't know i'm just saying i'm
watching tyson fury fight and i'm like
who could beat this guy and then i
started thinking like historically who
could beat him i think tyson fury is the
greatest heavyweight boxer of all time
stop
everybody go falls when i say it just
tell me the guy that can beat him yeah
you're telling me real quick
six foot nine inch tyson fury he does
look he's [ __ ] huge he's gonna get
beaten by five foot ten inch mike tyson
knockout muhammad ali what six one
george foreman
six three and what did the top what did
he weigh 220 pounds at his top he was
probably hovering around 208 to 11 when
he was fighting like 277 george foreman
is closest 6'4 but if ali is out boxing
if ali is outboxing george foreman
imagine what's going to happen when a
guy six nine is in front of him with
great foot movement fast hands
the only person i can think of is lennox
lewis because i was going to pitch him
no here's the thing he's just because he
was huge because he was big he's tall he
had great reach and great power but
here's the thing he also gave one of my
favorite interviews after a fight where
he he it's like he i think he lost and
but that british accent he was like did
he even throw one jab
it was
fully canadian
yeah no i just chose to use the british
accent he went madonna yeah exactly but
the point is i'm watching like if lennox
lewis is the only guy that can beat
tyson fury right
nobody considers lennox lewis the
greatest heavyweight of all time yeah
yeah but this is what i was saying last
week or on patreon
it just moves forward like if you put
giannis he's not the greatest basketball
player of all time but if you drop them
in the 60s they're not gonna know what
the [ __ ] this thing is because
everything just moves forward yeah yeah
people get better at their respect
people get better they get bigger they
get faster they get stronger everything
they just somehow as time passes we just
get more and more dynamic at everything
yeah so tyson might be able to beat any
heavyweight going back but that doesn't
make them the greatest heavyweight ever
yeah you got to put them in their time
and consider them in their time and
that point real quick okay just to that
point
if things get better as we go along yeah
we're currently according to that
argument in the best
right yes because things are getting
better and if this is the best guy
of now which is the best version of the
sport he's the best ever
yeah you used greatest is where i
tripped up the first time he said he's
the greatest heavyweight ever i think
grades is a little different best sure
he might be able to beat any of these
guys because of the era we're in and 20
years from now there'll be a lot of
people who beat the [ __ ] out of this guy
that's just how timely but we're not
there but if we're talking great
relative to your time i don't know
boxing but i'm assuming it's going to be
an ali who fought
foreman and frazier and list and whoever
else as opposed to ties and fury
that's it with like a [ __ ] heart was
5 10.
i agree
yeah but think about it wilder was
touching fury and wilder's not a great
boxer yo he's just a slugger if you put
ali in front of him yes he's shorter but
he's an actual boxer and can touch it
let me give a little push back about
that so deontay wilder
is six seven
what a lot of people don't realize about
deontay wilder is like what he lacks in
skills he makes up uh for in the fact
that he's the hardest puncher in the
history of boxing he had 42 fights
before that fighting 41 and then a
knockout that's the highest knockout
percentage in history he's the hardest
puncher in history nobody's close
probably right so when you're six seven
you can have kind of shitty fundamentals
because you're so much taller than
people you're fighting they have to take
risks in order to hit you and the second
they take those risks boom game over he
goes up against a guy six nine who can
actually keep him out there and he still
fights him well
it's like
i i'm telling you i don't see anybody
inc i know this sounds blasphemous but
you're not leaving that's wrong if
you're not i know what you mean i see
your point yeah there's just physics
here it's like yeah who's gonna touch
him yeah if and everybody goes linux and
i think that's reasonable but if we're
going lennox as the only guy but lennox
also wasn't like dominant he was like
the champ but he wasn't like he got beat
goddamn it wasn't like he murdered
people yeah
um i mean yeah i know he got i just
think i know it's crazy to say
but if you really sit down and look at
it and you're like who could be could
mike tyson beat him there's no way in
hell
there's no way i don't even know if he
could reach him
he could literally just stand up
straight in front of him i don't even
know if mike is reaching him with the
punches yeah but mike would get close
like mike styles i'm do what going like
this i'm going to take some hits while
i'm getting close to you and once i'm
close now i'm i'm biting you i'm taking
it to the body and i'm getting close
with that big old jab yeah i'm telling
you he would just run through that [ __ ]
he just walks in like this just takes
punches i'm telling you mike could do it
and i think ali would be able to do it
nah bro because ali could take a lot of
punishment he could take the punishment
yeah but how close is he to deontay
wilder who ties the fury closest he in
terms of what in terms of skill in terms
of i think he's significantly better
yeah but dante's got the equalizer which
is the power if he touches you you go
down um there's nothing you could do
turns it off it's so funny how unpopular
it is like heavyweights used to be the
only game in town and now i'm like who
yeah
like when you talk about i'm like is
that the big fat guy is that yeah like
you know what i mean like are you an mma
at all
not even a little really it's actually
too violent for me interesting my dad
says the same thing and he's a huge
boxing fan i was watching boxing this
time them too i was like this is too
this is like these guys are all getting
concussions it's crazy you get a
concussion then you get back up and you
keep fighting yeah and you just a couple
rounds in you're back to hopefully back
to normal that's the thing with mma is
like people think mma is way more brutal
because you hit someone when they're on
the ground right right but the reality
is letting somebody get back up after
they were concussed yeah and keep
fighting yes even while their knees are
still wobbling that's what it is it's a
war crime
[ __ ] warcraft torture yeah it's
insane that we allow that right yeah so
it's actually apparently way worse for
you boxing
well because you get hit so much more
yeah sustained punishment football is
kind of too violent for me they say that
boxing football is the same thing it's
like that constant like you're just
knocking it constantly whereas mma it's
like one big shot lights out
ref jumps in there yeah you're taking
less punishment it's mostly getting
split you're like bleeding a lot more
yeah and also there's more costs to buy
i also don't be honest
your hand hurts you i don't like the
barefoot thing
i don't want to see feet i don't want to
see feet
i thought you were gonna you [ __ ] up
bare knuckle no you never heard a
barefoot boxing barefoot box it's really
popular it's getting really popular you
were like seeing the feet no dude there
was a gnarly thing that happened in this
fight this guy kicks a guy in the face
right he does like an upkick kicks a guy
in his face
breaks his big toe when he does it right
he's he goes back down to like plant his
feet and this assume that's the big toe
this big toe is just pointing up
right and as he's looking at the other
guy he looks down at it takes his other
foot
just pushes the big toe back down onto
the canvas keeps on fighting
he would i think he'd step on his own
[ __ ] broken toe yeah but
surprisingly surprisingly toes aren't
that big of a deal like when i used to
do karate i broke three toes like
kicking and [ __ ] like that
i broke both like it doesn't hurt that
much it doesn't mess up your balance
that much really
if there's nothing there's also nothing
they can do big toes oh yeah they just
say don't walk on it or something yeah
yeah if you break your big toe i would
think you're [ __ ] i wouldn't it's not
that bad but apparently you can just
step on it
yeah yeah did you try stepping on it i
didn't i didn't try it actually
yeah i just i waited
you didn't like competition in
competition just kept going just kept
going
adrenaline you don't feel it and then
afterwards it hurts a little bit but it
doesn't hurt that much
it was different once one time was a big
toe and then the other times that pinky
and then yeah
yo sorry a couple questions i had about
the wilder fighter you saw the replay
first of all wilder looked like a better
boxer this time like he looked yeah
usually i watch him he just looks crazy
also here's one question fury would put
wilder in this headlock a lot and the
ref would always break it up yeah fury's
first knocked down a wilder he popped
him got him once then put him in a
headlock then uppercutted him the
classic uh the move nice that's right
using the arm hook and basketball to
drive it's like
kind of dirty but you get everybody does
it you use this hand or what depends
whatever but you use one hand to kind of
hold their head down yeah and then you
uppercut with the other but if you're
really good you keep the ref on the hand
holding side
so if the ref is right here you just put
the hand here and then you uppercut
with the left so the ref can't see you
because the refuge hey that's illegal
you can't hold his head down and punch
him at the same time but yeah he this is
a guy like the furies have been fighting
since they're four years old they're
they're gypsies
yeah like that legit gypsies like not
like we're playing around for this for
like the title he looks like he trains
only outside he has a winnebago yeah it
doesn't surprise me in the slightest
that they go living sometimes yep he
doesn't surprise the innocent that's the
life that they call them the travelers
you're not supposed to use gypsy and he
just said uh well no i'm gonna use gypsy
and he's also the baddest guy on the
planet so he's like i guess you can just
do that if you want but like that is the
[ __ ] life and they fight they're
called like fighting men
and yeah it could be in a field on some
like brad pitt and lock stock [ __ ] was
it knocks out or yeah snatch
snatch probably yeah don't know
but like but yeah of course man it's
rare you're never going to get that a
guy six nine in america is playing
basketball or football and he would
never be brought to a boxing gym out of
his mind if he was brought together you
talk about head movement sometimes with
boxers i notice it with fury oh it's
[ __ ] crisp dude just in and out slip
slip slip bang when he knocked him out
he dipped the [ __ ] punch yeah caught
him with it over him right yeah
unbelievable it really is a difference
of doing something your whole life
and getting into something kind of later
and like figuring it out even though one
is like an elite athlete and the other
one's just sort of like a massive guy
yeah you guys i went to the script
um canelo fight oh dude and i was which
one the they had it the second one
second one and i was i was front row
and
uh
at one point um they're like they're
eight feet from me right yeah yeah and
at one point uh canelo punched triple g
this
this and he didn't blink
i was like oh this these guys this is
some other [ __ ] bro they're my uh the
guy that i train with right he used to
be on the egyptian olympic team right
and he's won a bunch of like world
titles and that kind of stuff this is an
amateur uh hossam abdeen great trainer
you should go train with him in new york
but uh
he said they used to do a drill where
they would take a glove not in a hand
but just a glove outside of a hand and
you'd leave your eyes open and they
would just punch you in the face with
the not with your hand in the glove yeah
holding just like getting used to it
just so you get used to not blinking
while a punch is coming at your face
yeah the most basic human instinct there
is yeah and they they beat it